comment allez-vous en ce très cher
confinement jours a connu car je sais
pas quand cette vidéo sort il ya
quelques semaines dans une vidéo on
avait regardé des trucs hyper émouvant
hyper beau hyper positif et c'est très
agréable
et en ces temps de confinement j'ai
envie de vous dire que c'est une bonne
idée de le refaire je trouve je suis
assez content de tourner la suite parce
que le fait de ne pas sortir bas je vois
pas trop positif en fait enfin je veux
dire il ya des trucs que je faisais dans
mon quotidien qui était qu'on leur dise
bonjour à un vendeur à un café ou dans
un restaurant
c'est con mais je trouvais ça cool des
interactions avec des inconnus comme ça
par ci par là et des fois des bonnes
surprises
là il ya plus à quoi c'est horrible bref
la dernière fois les lecteurs de pierres
les plus solides d'entre vous n'ont pas
succombé à verser une petite larme
aujourd'hui ça va être d'autres genres
de vidéos tout aussi émouvante et tout
aussi cool qui vont nous faire du bien
rappelez vous que le monde c'est aussi
ça allez c'est parti préparez-vous et si
vous pleurez c'est de joie et c'est une
bonne chose voilà me culpabiliser par
relâcher vous la réaction de mon mari
comme notre fils de 11 mois a fait ses
premiers pas au ils ont ça en vidéo
[ __ ] balèze
[Musique]
oh
o o j'aimerais que ce soit moi qui fais
mes premiers pas et voir une telle
fierté dans le regard de mon père a trop
mignon trop mignon je sais pas ce que ça
fait de voir son enfant faire ses
premiers pas mais ça doit être quelque
chose toujours pertinent c'est comment
or le moment où elle a appris que son
adoption avait été accepté au nom
ou ou s'il m'a fait mal je suis je suis
contemporaine je suis vraiment content
pour elle put un grand mère a toujours
voulu colorées ses cheveux elle a enfin
fait le par aux assignats c'est génial
quelle est osé bravo madame nous tout ça
est ne nous mentons pas on a tous voulu
se faire un petit kiff comme ça j'en
reçois il ya plein de gens qui voulaient
stern en blond par exemple les causes et
pas moi j'avais l'excusé parfaite avec
bye bye je suis une belle [ __ ] ans
j'ai fait premier degré en vengeur nommé
pour le clip c'est la blague je suis
vraiment une merde c'est fou comme
parfois on a trop envie de faire un truc
mais on a peur du regard des autres et
du coup on s'empêche de le faire et là
je trouve ça génial qu'elle ait fait le
pas en fait même à cet âge là c'est trop
bien trop émouvant que j'avais 8 ans
j'ai offert un trèfle à quatre feuilles
à mon père pour lui porter chance
et quand il est mort je me suis rendu
compte qu'il l'avait scotchées au dos de
son portefeuille pendant 20 ans c'est
fou comme les humains peuvent être qu'on
lui on le sait tous mais c'est fou comme
ils peuvent être si mignon aussi encore
un truc obvious même un auteur voit pour
la première fois quelqu'un qui sait
cosplay ans l'un des personnages de son
livre
oh non il va et ça ça doit être ça doit
être choquant 12
sutil deux jours je vois ce qu'il a
l'air si doux et gentil ce gars je veux
ce genre d'amitié quand j'aurai cet âge
oh non ça va être assez mort vieux
également enfin mort genre nous on va
mourir devant sa part ohlala mais c'est
abusé c'est abusé cette gestuelle de
gars de 20 ans alors qu'ils ont 65
c'est fou au nom ses petits enfants ont
voulu faire une surprise à la grand mère
à l'aéroport en s'habillant t-rex mais
elle a appris la surprise et elle a
décidé elle de les surprendre fois c'est
compliqué
[Musique]
aa trouvé un trop bien non un papa de 85
en pleurs après que ses enfants aient
retrouvé son copain de guerre qu'il n'a
ni vu ni entendu depuis plus de 60 ans
au nom il ya la totale la ja le vétéran
de guerre personnes âgées amitié à total
tout à il manque juste un chien et c'est
le combo
[Musique]
actuellement un retard ont ils ont assez
mal mais jusqu aux oreilles comme dirait
maurice est ce ma grand mère ouah c'est
vraiment l'émotion pure et dure là qui
parle c'est ouf theory maîtresse une
guerre c'est le lien que ça doit de
créer avec les autres qui sont avec toi
ça doit être ma vie on voit la [ __ ]
j'avais promis que j'arrête d'être comme
j'ai mis mon fils dans une école privée
il était hyper triste de se séparer de
son meilleur ami barrette ça fait trois
mois qu'il est dans cette école et
aujourd'hui le professeur a annoncé
l'arrivée d'un nouvel élève
et devinez quoi ces barrettes ça quel
château il n'ya pas d'empathie qui roule
moi j'ai déménagé deux fois à chaque
fois je te jure mon meilleur pote il
n'arrivait pas dans la même école que
moi après trois mois même après 3,1
d'ailleurs mais bien joué bien joué à
lui c'est beau il y a quinze ans ma mère
a perdu le diamant de sa bague de
mariage pendant ses 15 ans elle a du
coup pas porter la bague
aujourd'hui mon père lui a fait une
surprise c'est la même bague mais
claudia manches auxquelles google
keith b g
[Musique]
non mais c'est quoi si famille parfaite
l'a adoptée mme roy a bien je comprends
le symbole des recettes bagley ouf
tu vois 15 ans avec la personne ne t'a
pas pu la mettre parce qu'elle perd du
diamant franchement trop mais un mais
[ __ ] mais remballez vos familles
parfaite la fesci
regardez c'est un père pilote avec son
fils pilote en direction du dernier vol
de la carrière du père après 41 ans de
service chez air canada tarn et vous
arrêtez d'être parfait millions tout
cela terrible comment les vrais bonhomme
fonds pour savoir qui va prendre la
place de parking
pierre faye soft est sûre ça résout tous
les problèmes avec leur vaisseau
vraiment c'est génial mais que ça
devrait être dans la loi et l'a perdu
il a perdu là sourire comment il fait ne
mentez pas vous et moi on n'a pas souri
à corrompre arrête nous ont insultés on
prend la place qu'aurait c'est génial ce
genre de petits jeux qui s'instaure
entre des gens je trouve ça tellement
bien en fait c'est assez logique en
break et ça je sais pas pourquoi des
fonds on en arrive à ces insultes et
pour une place de parking quoi vont fait
pitié quand même aux non regardez c'est
un père qui fait la réussite de sa fille
c'est horrible regarder rien et il l'est
du bois dans son truc et il fait gérant
note à gagner qui fait genre certes mais
c'est horrible
en fait je me dis imaginez il fait ça
pendant dix ans elle va arriver à
l'adolescence à la croire qu'avec les
genres trop forte c'est la meilleure du
monde et où est la désillusion
james harrison 81 ans a fait son dernier
don du sang vendredi dernier en
australie son sang contenait un
anticorps assez rares utilisées dans des
traitements qui ont officiellement sauvé
la vie de plus de deux millions de bébés
il a donné son sang 1173 fois de ses 14
à 81 ans
franchement si vous pouvez donner votre
sang comme le don d'organes donner son
sang c'est un peu plus contraignant
parce que il faut bloquer de mes
journées est arrive tu te prends une
aiguille extra fins pas forcément
agréable c'est un effort qu'il faut
faire et ben lui l'a fourni cet effort
pendant 67 oh trop bien l'année dernière
le fils de cet homme est mort dans un
accident de voiture il a décidé de
donner son coeur à un autre ce mois ci
le destinataire du coeur lui a envoyé ce
cadeau il a enregistré les battements de
son coeur et les amis dans un ours pour
que ce papa puisse entendre le cas de
son fils battre
il en a envie
[Musique]
à cette fois mais le fait d'avoir mis
dedans un ours en peluche que sa fille
qui est venue pour noël et le meilleur
cadeau qu'elle ait eu de toute sa vie
art et les trucs de famille ça me touche
aussi ptah je m'en rends compte là nous
un facteur la famille ça me termine
assez un miroir est allé derrière
non mais c'est incroyable ce set up
elle a valu encore trop bien au lit les
numéros à l'incroyable on va tout cela
vole et tu imagines pas la joie de mon
nom j'ai déjà arrêté jallet recommencer
j'allais vraiment dire j'imagine pas la
joie que ça fait de moi un proche
après l'avoir vu pendant vraiment
longtemps incroyable bon c'est une
personne qui a rencontré un ami
d'enfance à elle dans la rue et qui
était homeless et qui avaient de sérieux
soucis avec la drogue
et cet ami lui a dit vas-y je veux
démarrer une nouvelle ville j'en peux
plus d'être d'être dans la drogue dans
la rue j'en ai marre et elle a fait une
cagnotte sur internet pour pouvoir lui
payer un centre de réhabilitation de
désintox et la cagnotte a reçue assez
d'argent du coup il a pu y aller et
voilà le avant et le après foi en
l'humanité restaurer un soldat pleurs
après que sa copine lui rendre visite
par surprise le jour de son anniversaire
n'arrêtait des trucs avec les soldats
c'est trop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais qu'est-ce qui parut j'ai craqué
déjà tellement de fois l'agent peu plus
ses bras en fait que c'est au mental
brickdown je crois tout fait pleurer
bordel de merde on va écouter les amis
c'est la fin de cette deuxième vie elle
a été dure mais franchement c'était dur
la fois je crois que j'ai trouvé le truc
qui me tue le plus moi c'est les trucs
de retrouvailles en fait à chaque fois
et dia dans la dérision c'est ce qui
m'avait tu es là le vétéran qui avait
retrouvé ses chiens en fait ce soit avec
des animaux ou juste entre humains ce
truc de retrouver quelqu'un après un
moment et ai appris qu était manquée de
ouf [ __ ] quand tu le vois visuellement
ça te va si dur pour ce qu'ont toujours
pas été ému cca il ya un problème d'
empathie là quelque part c'est pas
possible non je refuse de croire que
quelqu'un n'a pas été ému du tout
partout ça c'est pas possible
en tout cas je suis content ça fait
vraiment du bien avec les temps qui
courent je pense pas dire c'est un jeu
au près d'avoir vu ça franchement avoir
des bonnes actions entre humains des
retrouvailles de l'amour de la
bienveillance et tous et c'est ça qui
doit primer sur le reste en fait et on a
tendance à l'oublier mais en vrai je
suis convaincu qu'on n'est pas si loin
quoi passer comme le rester chez vous en
fait c'est même principe chacun j'ai de
son côté à l'arrivée tout le monde se
tire vers le haut c'est génial voilà
c'est la fin un petit peu émouvante une
morale un peu un peu augustin comme tout
comme les trois quarts des commentaires
bref j'ai adoré on va pas refaire avoir
moment le confinement il me il me met à
fleur de peau de malades vis-à-vis de
ces trucs là je suis 10 fois plus émotif
que d'habitude ça pas du tout prenez
soin de vous jeter à 13,2 prochaine
vidéo c'était très très cool allez à
bientôt
c'est ciao
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]